hello everybody
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for february 10
2021 ladies and gentlemen i am in
a fan freaking tax-tastic
amazing super-duper mood because
right after this live stream i'm getting
on a plane
and i'm going to the free state of
florida
i'm going to eat fresh fish i'm going to
sit
on the beach i am going to see other
human beings
often with leathery leathery tans
i'm gonna do all that and so much more
in the free state of florida i cannot
wait i'm going
for 10 days uh we taped a whole bunch of
stuff in advance so you're still going
to get
some new interviews and some new panel
shows and a bunch more fear not and by
the way
next week of course is presidents week
and
we will be re-releasing uh some episodes
that we've done that we're going to put
up some
some bites to longer episodes that we've
done
that we're focused on some of the
presidents of the past so maybe you'll
learn a little something
about some of those guys like lincoln
and jfk and john adams and more
so that'll be for next week and i'm just
very
very
excited and if you want to see what i'll
be doing because i'm really not going to
be on social media if you want to see
what i'm going to be doing in florida
you know wrestling alligators and all
that kind of stuff join me over at
reubenreport.locals.com i'll be hanging
out
over there from the beach and the rest
of it uh okay guys before
i get to it and we've got a whole bunch
of stories to roll through today and i
am going to defend
the honor of the great state of florida
before i head there
uh that's going to be the first story i
want to talk to you guys about
ancestry.com you know there are many
paths
to finding your family's story whichever
way you choose
tracing your family generations back
with a family tree or uncovering your
ethnicity
with ancestry dna it's easy to get
started with ancestry you could find a
famous relative or perhaps a photo of
your great grandma
as a little girl whatever you find is
sure to change
the whole way you look at your family
history and yourself
after all the story of your family is
the story of you
with the ongoing pandemic it's easy to
feel disconnected from your loved ones
but researching your history is a fun
activity the whole family can enjoy
and the stories you learn about your
shared past can bring you closer
together
i've actually done ancestry and i also
have a genealogist in my
family who has traced uh my family back
on my mom's side to like the mid 1700s
already it's actually pretty amazing
ancestry dna can reveal ethnic origins
and provide historical details
that bring unique family stories to life
ancestry dna doesn't just tell you which
countries you're from but can also
pinpoint the specific regions within
them
giving you insightful geographic detail
about your history trace the paths of
your recent ancestors and learn how
and why your family moved from place to
place around the world
no other dna test delivers such a unique
interactive experience grab
excuse me grab an ancestry dna kit and
start a free trial to amplify your
discoveries
with ancestry's billions of records
start exploring your family story today
head to my url at ancestry.com
reuben to get your ancestry dna kit and
start your free trial that's
ancestry.com
reuben and now back to me okay i want to
talk about florida because i am heading
to florida and i don't know if you could
tell but i'm super excited okay
we're still in some level of bizarro
lockdown here i don't know what's going
on in california
but florida is a wonderful state led by
a decent human being by the name of ron
desantis
there are people out there doing things
living life
despite the pandemic it's an incredible
way of living life not being in crippled
fear
at all moments so i'm very very excited
to get there shortly
but uh you know i usually uh hand it to
cnn on this show right almost every day
at this point i do
something about cnn because cnn is not a
news organization anymore it's just it's
just an arm of the democratic party and
it's just awful
misinformation guys as information and
blah blah blah you guys get it
i saw this clip going around the twitter
from msnbc this is on the joe
scarborough
show talking about ron desantis and
what's happening in florida
and i really want you to listen to it
and listen to the tone
that they're using as they talk about
what's happening in florida and then
guess what guys i don't want to spoil it
for you
i'm going to give you some facts using
actual
data to show you that these two people
are idiots here we go
obviously florida remains a hot spot
the variant looks like it could spread
very quickly around this state and mika
vaccinations continue to go at an
unbelievably slow rate yeah i know the
the vaccine process
is is painfully slow i mean there are
people who are in categories who
you know are definitely apply for it
right now like my mother
people over the age of 70 who cannot get
it and then you see video of
kids squashed together screaming at each
other
probably drinking i mean this is just a
nightmare well that is a coveted
nightmare
you talk about your mother there's
somebody who's 89 who has
parkinson's she can't get the vaccine
she hasn't been able to get a vaccine
uh and we know a lot of people uh
who are in their mid to late 70s
80s who have underlying conditions in
florida
can't get their vaccines either
seriously
how hard uh has this been i know that
ron desantis has been stumbling
around over the past year or so and has
had some real problems
especially as it's pertained to vaccines
but i don't think anybody would have
expected him
to foul it up as badly as he has
all right joe so you don't think anyone
would have expected
ron desantis to foul it up as badly as
it has
leaving his state largely open in the
midst of this whole thing now notice
what they did not give you there on the
joe scarborough
msnbc program was any stats right in
that whole thing there they talk about
very emotional things about her mother
and
okay oh and old people can't this and
joe uh rhonda sanders must be a bad man
so i thought guys maybe we'll give stats
on the show today
facts and stats and i have got a team of
uh people here who dive into the numbers
so we're gonna show some numbers right
now so first let's show the percentage
of vaccinations
administered to seniors this is from
seniors first
okay florida is actually
way ahead of everyone else in
administering vaccines
to seniors as you can see right there
it's orange way ahead of everyone else
so they are vaccinating the most amount
of seniors
by the way as we've talked about before
florida has the second
oldest population in the united states
by state so you would think their
numbers would be tremendously higher
because not only
have they been open but they also have
this old population and obviously older
people are going to have comorbidities
and everything else
but not only are their numbers not as
high
but they've actually vaccinated the most
amount of people by percentage
but look at this next thing about deaths
now if you were listening to joe
scarborough there
ron desantis is killing an awful lot of
people they don't know what they're
doing and everything else
well how about deaths per state by a
hundred thousand people this is from
statista
okay this is using numbers and data
well it turns out that florida is 26th
in deaths per hundred thousand meaning
that they have 129 deaths
per 100 000 people in the state new
jersey
and new york with andrew cuomo who wrote
the book on great leadership
uh during a pandemic uh they need new
jersey and new york
are one and two and uh in effect
florida is about well it's a little less
little less than half of that
so per hundred thousand people florida
is 26th in the nation without doing all
of the draconian
lockdowns and everything else so just to
be clear if you're watching and this is
what the problem is guys
if if your average blue pilled friend
not that anyone's really watching
msnbc but i know but somebody is and
these clips go around and then people
get brainwashed
if you watch that clip they didn't give
you any charts they didn't give you any
number they didn't give you any
statistics they give you this overly
emotional situation now i hope that
her mother who's 80 whatever with
parkinson's i hope she's able to get the
vaccine and i would want to know more as
to why she hasn't been able to get it
because it does seem like it's going
pretty well in florida
but notice they didn't show you oh here
are the amount of people being
vaccinated here is how it stacks up to
the other states
and here are the amount of deaths that
we've had in this state relative to
everything else
oh and by the way we kept people uh
job we kept people uh working and let
them
go to jobs and kept the state open and
everything else
and it's just it's just really dangerous
what they're doing like they don't like
florida
because florida is republican it voted
for
the orange man with the crazy hair who
they're doing the sham impeachment for
now they don't like that guy
and that's what they're doing but it's
important for you guys to see these
things and you know what let's do this
can we put the links to these two
studies in the uh
in the description all right we're going
to put the links to the two studies in
this
description so that if you have a family
member who is someone that is
brainwashed that is watching msnbc and
watches that and just says to you but
florida's the worst it's the worst
joe scarborough said it and that lady
he's sitting next to
well then you can go you know what
you're not going to believe this i have
i have a link here
to some data and i know dad is racist
but you got a chance then you got you
maybe you got a chance
all right guys let me talk to you about
raycon i've got
the earbuds right here in my hand people
i can't have them in my ear at the
moment because i've got my little ifb
there so i can hear the clips when we
play them but i've got the beautiful
raycon air buds right here as you know
as you guys know uh you know once a year
i like to go off the grid for the month
of august but as you can imagine
unplugging is easier said than done
and what about the other 11 months of
the year i still need my time away
from screens and devices fortunately by
putting in my new raycon wireless
earbuds i have found a way to rest my
eyes without missing the important
content i need to do my job and live my
best life
whether you're catching up on reuben
report episodes listening to the
audiobook version of don't burn this
book which i read myself
or powering through your workout with a
pumped up playlist
a pair of raycons in your ears can make
all the difference
these things are super super clear like
you will seriously be impressed
i was trying them this week and they
really are great uh they've got no
dangling wires or stems raycons come in
a range of stylish
colors and are always comfortable and
have an in-ear fit for a more discreet
look
raycons are built to perform anywhere
and anytime with water and sweat
resistant construction i am heading to
the beach and i'll be bringing them with
me
and bluetooth that pairs quickly and
seamlessly and with enough battery life
for six hours of playtime you can unplug
for a while
the best part raycon makes great sound
accessible to everyone
with wireless earbuds starting at half
the price of other premium audio brands
raycon is offering 15 off their products
for my listeners and here's what you got
to do to get it go too
by raycon dot com slash ruben that's it
you'll get 15
off your entire raikon order so feel
free to grab a pair
and despair that's 15 off at buy raycon
that's b
u y r a y c o com reuben by raycon.com
reuben and now back to me i mean
seriously look how tiny these things are
like they're just tiny
and they fit you know what i mean like
you always put these things in they
don't quite fit in the air
these things actually fit uh all right
let's shift
to syrup people okay let's shift to high
fructose corn syrup
let's shift to aunt jemima i don't want
to get canceled i just said aunt jemima
uh you may remember that uh over the
last few months we've we've cancelled a
lot of
tv shows we've cancelled a lot of
products the land of lakes woman is no
longer on there
uh and then we took out aunt jemima do
we still have uncle ben or his uncle ben
been taken out
we're just taking out everybody in the
name of tolerance we're erasing history
in the name of tolerance because that's
what all good
tolerant evolved societies do well you
may remember a few months back
they officially announced the the parent
company of aunt
jemima announced that they were going to
get rid of aunt jemima
so they finally did they got rid of aunt
jemima and they released
the new bottle with the new name can we
put that up there
so aunt jemima on the left which
everyone knows and loves like
everyone had that in their in their
cupboard as a kid and mom used to put
that on your pancakes aunt jemima okay
remember aunt jemima well it is now the
pearl
milling company
i don't know what pearl milling is pearl
milling sounds like someone's name
she might have been a racist for all we
know but we've eliminated
ant jemima we have stopped racism
things will be better now because we
took out aunt jemima aunt jemima who was
a former slave by the way
uh and this is from npr so green so her
last name was green
angelima was a former slave who moved to
chicago to work as a caretaker
for a prominent white family she was
hired to portray a living version of the
character at the 1893 world's fair
according to her obituaries
she was later hired to play the role for
her pancake company
her pancake company until her death npr
goes on
although the name aunt jemima is well
known green
is not and one chicago historian worries
that removing the ant jemima image could
erase green's legacy
and the legacies of many black women who
worked as caretakers and cooks
for both white families and their own so
look aunt jemima was based on a real
person
she was a slave she was a good woman
okay there's no doubt about any of that
this was something that existed that no
one in their right mind no one of
any rational sane thought was pouring
aunt jemima pancake
syrup onto their pancakes and doing it
in the name of racism no one
didn't buy it because they were racist
and they didn't want
a black woman on their syrup bottle we
have done some very odd things with
removing statues and destroying
uh destroying names of products and
eliminating
characters and tv shows you know i
mentioned uh that hulu now no longer
shows an episode of the golden girls
where uh god it's so stupid it's it's
incredible
where blanche and rose are doing face
masks right women like to do face masks
they're doing like some sort of face
mask
and they come out and it appears that
they're in blackface and it's very funny
because at the time dorothy
dorothy's uh son is about to marry a
black woman the whole episode is about
people coming together and getting over
racism and that there's more important
things that bring us together beyond our
skin color but they've decided to take
that episode off hulu um
do you think by removing that episode of
the golden girls or
getting rid of aunt jemima or taking out
the lando lakes woman like does anything
seem better
like literally anything is anyone
benefiting by any of this
i think it's fairly obvious what the
answer is so
i'm not gonna you know buy the pearl
milling
syrup the thing is by the way that if
i'm not mistaken aunt jemima the number
one ingredient anyway was
high fructose corn syrup which you
should probably just buy regular maple
syrup but that's no offense to
antamima tastes have changed over the
over the years we've learned
that different things are healthier or
not so i'm gonna go for the straight up
vermont maple
okay that's me but
it's just so stupid oh i've got an
update on
uncle ben in september of 2020
uncle ben's rice changed its name to
ben's original and removed the image of
a smiling gray-haired black man
from its packaging
so we had uncle ben's rice then they
just call it ben's original but the
important thing is we got rid of the old
smiling black man
because we're not racist those people
were racist
oh my god it's so
yeah it's it's really it's so
mind-numbing it's like how is this
happening in front of us
and i really think that the the future
of this country if
if we are to continue in any sensible
way which i'm writing a book about right
now actually
if we are to continue we basically are
going to have to have a parallel economy
for like it'll be the woke people can
have their economy and they will have no
names on anything and there will be no
people on anything
and they will destroy everything and
that'll be it
and then there will be like a sane
economy and the same economy
will allow for competition and a little
bit of history
and a little bit of ingenuity and fun
and joking and all of that stuff
and you'll have to pick which side you
want to be on so it'll be like a
it'll be almost like a digital civil war
in a way which in many ways is happening
already right i mean big tech has
has put their foot on so many people
conservative leaning let's say or just
not
woke that we may be in a digital civil
war already so
lordy lordy what are you gonna do uh
guys so one of the things that i really
enjoyed about this week and that we
absolutely are going to continue and i i
checked all the responses and you guys
were loving it too
is that i found this video of ronald
reagan in 1975 this is about
four years before he ran for president
but he was already wrapped up
his term as a republican governor of
california yes believe it or not
california once had republican governors
and our recall now is a hundred thousand
votes away less actually
uh in terms of recalling gavin newsom
and we've got until march
16th to do it so i'm pretty sure that's
going to happen and i really do believe
this
like as excited as i am to go to florida
today like
if we can recall gavin newsom maybe that
is the first
domino that falls that starts knocking
down everything else
that we can really get rid of
politicians who do things for themselves
and their own political interests rather
than the people this guy has ruined
the state he was the mayor of san
francisco as you know he ruined san
francisco
which is now an absolute nightmare and
now he moved on like a locust
to ruining the state so i think if we
can get rid of him it might show other
people in other states oh
you can actually get rid of these people
using the democratic system wouldn't
that
be something in any event i i do cardio
to these old interviews and i've watched
a whole bunch of stuff from
from johnny carson and i've been
watching a lot of old thomas soul videos
and all this different stuff but i found
this this interview of ronald reagan
as i said between governor and what
would eventually become his eight-year
term as president
talking to johnny carson about thinking
about running for president
and what he felt was wrong in the
country and everything else so we played
a couple clips the last few days
uh now i'm going to play about a
two-minute clip uh him talking about
foreign policy and i think it's it's
actually pretty interesting
and uh and as i said before the the joe
scarborough clip that i just played
listen to the tone
just listen to the tone and the tenor uh
that which
he talks with like the and also his body
language and everything else
just listen to this and think man could
someone like this be president
these days and then we'll we'll unpack
it when we return
they took a poll of the american people
the past week and i think 78
or something around 75 percent were
opposed to more military
aid to vietnam and cambodia and
southeast asia in general
and yet the administration was
trying to tell the american people that
a couple hundred million or 222 million
dollars
would make some kind of difference or
that the government might make it and uh
how do you feel do you think that that
is a lost cause in a way i think people
can see humanitarian
you know for children hospitals etc
medical supplies and food
but it seems that the public has just
almost had it up with military
involvement where
we feel we are not directly threatened
well
we we are uh fed up we're war weary
after
a long and badly fought war on the other
hand and this is one where i'll probably
lose a lot of people because it isn't
popular or political
to say this today
when we withdrew our troops we made a
ceasefire a peace agreement
and it was based on uh
supporting the non-communist forces in
indochina
on a basis of one-for-one replacement
every bullet they expended a bullet to
replace it if the communists violated
the ceasefire
the communists have violated the
cease-fire 72 thousand times
since it was instituted and we brought
our men home
and i think for the united states to
break its word
we're in that agreement we pledge
something and the congress is now saying
that the united states reserves the
right to just break its word and not
what other allies ever going to trust us
and i
there's no question that backed by red
china and the soviet union
the communist forces in vietnam and
cambodia
are on their way to take those over they
do of course laos just automatically
falls
then they're on the edge of indonesia
140 million people which comes within 14
miles at its nearest point of the
philippines
the domino theory is is still a viable
theory
and yes it is and i i could see the
united states
one day being very very lonely
now it's a very funny thing that the
same forces that want to cut
our defense spending are the same ones
that want to
increase all these social services and
this social tinkering and experimenting
that hasn't worked
and every time it doesn't work they just
impose a more expensive program on top
of it
i think the american people if they
really look at all the facts
uh yes we want fiscal responsibility but
i think we also want a country that is
strong enough at all times that we can
say to any adventurous guys over there
on the other side of the water
you better look twice brother before you
start getting rough
that we can take care of ourselves
[Applause]
all right so there's a bunch of stuff
there first just again the general tone
and tenor and calmness and ability to
communicate and be clear about what he
thinks and why he thinks it
i just think is is so different than
what politicians have
these days and i made four bullet points
as i was listening to it originally
first off his general position there is
peace through strength that
you don't want to go to war that's what
he's saying at the end you better think
twice right like
basically you have a strong military so
that you don't have to go to war like
all these people that always say
okay we have to just cut cut cut cut cut
the military well then the bad guys
might be like oh
look at those guys let's get in there so
i'm not for nation building i'm not for
adventurous
wars overseas i would love to get us out
of afghanistan
i think one of the great things that
trump did was not get us into new wars
uh you know joe biden did vote for the
iraq war we're still
sort of half in iraq nobody exactly
knows why and really nobody knows why
we're in afghanistan at all
so the idea of peace through strength
that i totally agree on and by the way
that i wrote about that in my
section on foreign policy and don't burn
this book um the one that i thought was
particularly interesting was honor our
commitments
what ally will trust us i mean that is
deeply deeply important
that countries need to know that if the
united states says something we're gonna
we're gonna abide by it now you may
remember obama's red line in syria where
if assad used
uh chemical weapons that we were going
to do something and then they did and we
didn't do anything
i was you can find videos of me as a
lefty on the young turks way back when
this is like seven years ago now
saying we should have nothing to do with
syria and and turkey and some of the
other countries
should maybe have something to do with
it but we can't always do everything for
everybody but once we set a line
i mean it's like in your life if your
friends know you're a liar then they're
just not going to listen to you anymore
right
so i thought what he said there what
ally will trust us
then i thought generally he was there
talking about because obviously this was
after vietnam
he was talking about fighting communism
you think that's relevant to everything
that we've got going on there today that
we need to
be proud of what the american democratic
capitalist system
is and we should be exporting those
ideas not through weapons and bombs
but strengthening those ideas is
obviously a good idea
oh and then he made a point to say that
all the people that want to that want to
cut the military
that they love these social programs and
that is so true and again he's saying
this in 75 so this is like 45 years ago
basically
and we know now that we're in a time
where the entire government is based on
can we give more and more more more more
can we artificially raise
wages can we give all these things for
free we can't pay for any of it
so funny in one of the other clips that
i showed the other day he talks about
the deficits and the debt and they're
all just
way worse like we're a debtor nation
at this point and one day china might
call in the debt and it's a good thing
that we've got some guns because you
know the mafia operates when they call
you
and they want the money that you owe
them well unless you got a bigger gun
you're in a lot of trouble so in a weird
way our strong military is the one thing
that keeps us safe right now but
that's a whole other topic anyway i'm
absolutely going to continue to do these
types of things i'll find some things on
youtube we'll chop them up a little bit
just to give you a little bite that
things used to be a little saner and
maybe we can get back to that sanity
but i want to quickly do one more story
for you because i saw this and it's like
i know i focus a lot on the united
states here but there are other
countries
in the world there's at least four
others i did a little digging
at least four other countries uh so in
the uk there's some crazy nonsense
happening
uh with the schools right now so this is
from msn
and uh the names of winston churchill
and jk rowling will be removed from the
houses at a secondary school after their
views were branded intolerant
by teenage students pupils at seaford
head school in
east sussex stated that the wartime
prime minister was responsible for
torturing many
while the harry potter author was not
suitable
due to her words about the trans
community
parents were informed in a letter that
houses honoring these figures
would be renamed to ensure that they do
not promote prejudice and new titles
based
on local topography would be put to a
vote among the student body
of 11 to 18 year olds okay so uh for my
british audience out there i'm so
sorry that you're going through this and
uh these people
are fools and morons first off you
cannot let a bunch of 11
to 18 year olds decide what is true and
just and what you should be naming
things and who is prejudiced
and who is not uh winston churchill for
those who forget and i know people have
a short memory these days
he's the guy that stopped the nazis
remember you had that neville
chamberlain guy he was the prime
minister before
and uh basically was like okay hitler do
what you got to do hitler we'll be okay
right
you won't do anything to us and that
didn't quite work out and then winston
churchill
went in and actually helped us
stop the nazis did winston churchill
live a perfect life
he did not i mean there's many books you
can read about this many movies you can
watch you watch the first season
of the crown to see that he lived a very
complex life and absolutely
was not perfect there's several movies
over the last couple years about winston
churchill
but he fought the nazis i thought we're
supposed to be against nazis that would
be pretty good oh and this jk rowling
who
you know she did the harry potter thing
which apparently is popular with the
young people
all she said was that there are
biological differences
between boys and girls that's it she's
not anti-trans she doesn't want trans
people to be treated differently under
the law
she doesn't want them to be subjected to
bigotry
or anything else it's just not the case
but imagine what kind of adults let
children decide what the names of the
schools should be
or what the curriculum should be or
anything else we've allowed
the inmates to run the asylum and
clearly
this is not something that's just
happening in america actually there was
one other story i wanted to cover today
and maybe we'll get to it
when i get back but even french prime
minister macron is now saying that the
united states college campuses
are exporting this woke nonsense and now
it's harming the institutions of france
so everywhere that liberal democracies
exist
woke-ism is coming in and destroying
them it's happening in france it's
happening in the uk it's happening all
over the world
and we got to fight it and i hope you
will continue to fight it with me i have
nothing better to do and i suspect that
you don't either
this friday guys we've got a big
tech panel where we're going to talk
about censorship specifically related to
medical the medical community covid and
the law
and we're going to have dr drew you guys
all know dr drew we're going to have dr
zubin damania and viva fry who is a
lawyer so two doctors and a lawyer we're
going to talk about big tech
some of the legal ramifications what's
going on with kovid what you can and
can't say hopefully we won't be
demonetized
or have my channel deleted uh and by the
way part two
of my interview with the fabulous ayan
hersey ali
is up on the youtube right now we just
put it up this morning and of course the
full episode
is already up at reubenreport.locals.com
absolutely ad free
and on that note
i'm going to pack my bailing suit and
i'll see you
in sunny florida